you know as you said officially the
meeting is still off there's been no
announcement to counter the president's
cancellation letter of last week but if
you take a look at the diplomatic
posture it would suggest that
unofficially at least this meeting looks
like it's back on leaving Washington on
a road trip to Texas President Trump
this morning gave a thumbs up to how
talks with North Korea are proceeding I
just want to tell you we're doing very
well with North Korea our Secretary of
State has had very good meetings he's
meeting again today I believe they'll be
coming down to Washington on Friday the
president revealed today that kim
yeongcheol is expected to hand deliver a
response from kim jong-un to the
president's letter last week a letter is
going to be delivered to me from Kim
Jong Orden so I look forward to seeing
what's in the letter
president Trump also lowering
expectations for his planned meeting
with Kim jong-un saying if it happens it
may be just the beginning of the process
hopefully we'll have a meeting on the
12th that's going along very well but I
want it to be meaningful it doesn't mean
it gets all done at one meeting maybe
you have to have a second or a third and
maybe we'll have none the freeze maybe
we'll have none could also apply to
Robert Muller's request for an interview
with President Trump I want to see the
documents which trey Gowdy has never
seen which is outrageous I'm not going
to let my client testify the president's
outside attorney Rudy Giuliani told Fox
News today he has two conditions that
need to be met before an interview
access to rod Rosenstein so-called scope
memo outlining the areas Robert Muller
was authorized to investigate and access
to DOJ materials regarding the FBI
confidential informant who approached
several members of the Trump campaign if
and when we find that this was handled
appropriately and and there's some
evidence on which they could base this
phony investigation
well we haven't testified but if there
is no evidence which I assume there is
no evidence then I mean he shouldn't
testify the latest twist revealed in the
Russia investigation is the existence of
a memo written by former FBI director
Andrew
cabe about the firing of James Comey
sources tell Fox News that McCabe memo
details of meeting he had with Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein sources
say in that meeting Rosenstein said the
president asked him to include something
about Russia in his memo justifying
commis firing Rosen Stein told McCabe he
declined to do it a source tells FOX
News that President Trump simply asked
Rosen Stein to add a line about Comey
telling the president he wasn't under
investigation
the reference was not included in Rosen
Stein's final memo Rudy Giuliani also
tells Fox News that he has not yet begun
formal prep sessions with the president
for a possible interview with robert
muller but even if there isn't going to
be an interview Giuliani says he'd
probably still do those prep sessions
because the president's legal team will
want to write a report about it at some
point and need to have a great level of
detail and the president's understanding
before they write that report right John
the president announced a pardon today
and hinted at more action to come dinesh
d'souza the well-known conservative
filmmaker author and commentator who
pled guilty in 2014 to illegal campaign
contributions received a presidential
pardon today and then aboard Air Force
One on his way down to Texas the
president suggested that there may also
be pardons in store for Martha Stewart
and former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich who's serving the 14 year
prison sentence for corruption
interesting to note that both of those
people Stewart and Blagojevich appeared
on Celebrity Apprentice this did not sit
well with some of the president's
Democratic critics who believe that he
is sending a signal to people caught up
in the Russia investigation that he is a
pardoning kind of guy
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thanks